he deserves his reputation as possibly  the greatest actor of his generation and  what makes the best actor in the world  because in sports you can measure it  what is it about the best actor I've  never seen an actor so completely  consume himself in character in true  character work during the work when  Robert is playing Lewis and you're  looking at every single solitary piece  of footage you've ever shot on the man  every single moment he is Lewis he is  working moment to moment some acting  people suggest something the effect of  like there's a zillion choices out there  and any one of them is possible and any  one of them is great I actually don't  believe that at all if you are a really  in character you only have a few choices  if something weird were to happen at  this table right now there's not a  zillion ways Charlie Rose is going to  react there's probably about four ways  Charlie Rose will react all right and De  Niro has that down